der un-generalsekretär görisch der
sonderbeauftragte der un libyen hat
salami und bundesaußenminister maß ja
meine damen und herren
wie haben es verfolgt wir haben heute
nachmittag hier in berlin sehr intensive
und ernsthafte verhandlungen gehabt und
damit dazu beigetragen dass wir einen
neuen politischen anlauf einen neuen
politischen impuls geben deren
bemühungen im libyen-konflikt hoffnung
für die menschen und hoffnung auf
frieden zu erzeugen
und ich glaube dass man sagen kann dass
diese berliner libyen konferenz einen
wichtigen beitrag geleistet hat um die
friedensbemühungen der vereinten
nationen zur unterstützung das will ich
ausdrücklich sagen es geht darum das was
auch als vater immer wieder von antonio
guterres und einsame vorgeschlagen wurde
zu flankieren und dafür verbündete zu
suchen und zwar insbesondere verbündete
als diejenigen die den permanenten sitz
im sicherheitsrat der vereinten nationen
haben plus diejenigen die eine wichtige
rolle spielen in der frage wie es im
libyen weitergeht wir hatten deshalb
zwölf teilnehmer staaten china
frankreich russland großbritannien die
usa als die fünf permanenten mitglieder
des sicherheitsrates dazu ägypten die
vereinigten arabischen emirate italien
kongo die türkei und algerien
und alle waren wir uns einig plus die
regionalen organisationen die arabische
liga die europäische union und natürlich
vor allem die afrikanische union dass
wir eine politische lösung brauchen es
ist glaube ich gerade in den letzten
tagen noch einmal sichtbar geworden dass
es keine chance auf eine militärische
lösung gibt das würde allenfalls das
leiden der menschen vergrößern
wir haben uns geeinigt innerhalb dieser
anwesenden parteien auf einen
umfassenden plan wie es weitergeht
und ich möchte vor allen dingen auch
herrn salami und natürlich antonio
guterres ganz herzlich danken
aber ich glaube wir haben auch von
deutscher seite einen beitrag geleistet
der bundesaußenminister und ich aber ich
kann auch sagen dass alle teilnehmer
wirklich sehr konstruktiv
zusammengearbeitet haben
wir können feststellen dass alle einig
sind dass wir dieses waffenembargo
respektieren wollen und dass das
waffenembargo auch stärker kontrolliert
wird als das in der vergangenheit der
fall ist denn sonst werden wir sehen
dass diese militärische lösung doch
immer wieder nicht ausscheidet sondern
dass immer wieder versuche gemacht
werden
und alle waren sich einig dass die
dokumente die wir heute verabschiedet
haben auch im un sicherheitsrat
akzeptiert werden müssen so dass das
dann auch eine offizielle internationale
bestätigung bekommt und damit die
verpflichtung auf das waffenembargo noch
einmal an bedeutung gewinnt wir wissen
dass wir mit dem heutigen tag natürlich
nicht alle von probleme in libyen lösen
konnten sondern es sollen ein neuer
impuls sein und insofern war es sehr
wichtig dass die anwesenden libyschen
vertreter nämlich premierminister zu
rage und general haffter heute uns für
den nächsten schritt der gemacht werden
muss von dem beauftragten des
generalsekretärs in salami nämlich an
der zusammenkunft des 5 + 5
militärkomitees so wie es hier
vereinbart ist dass da für uns die namen
genannt wurden
das heißt dass jetzt eine einladung
erfolgen kann für dieses treffen
und dieses treffen muss dann auch die
grundlage sein um aus einer waffenruhe
einen wirklich gefestigten
waffenstillstand zu machen dieses
treffen wird noch in der nächsten woche
eingeladen und ich hoffe dass es dann
auch einen schritt voran sein wird gehen
wird wir haben
dann die zusage aller teilnehmer
bekommen dass bis zu diesem treffen des
55 komitees die teilnehmer der heutigen
konferenz gesagt haben dass sie keine
weiteren unterstützungsleistungen für
die lippischen sozusagen kontroversen
parteien leben werden und auch die
operationen einstellen solange der die
waffenruhe hält und ich glaube dass
heute der geist geschaffen wurde
dafür dass wir auf dem pfad den herr
salami gezeichnet hat mit den folgen
schritten auch wirklich voranschreiten
können wir haben einen sehr
verbindlichen prozess dazu wird damit
sicherlich gleich noch etwas gesagt
vereinbart wie wir engmaschig in kurzen
zeitabständen immer wieder als die
vertreter die heute zusammengekommen
sind uns verantwortlich fühlen für den
weiteren prozess der erarbeitet werden
muss und politische lösungen zu finden
um den waffenstillstand einzuhalten das
heißt um aus einem heute ja so ist stark
auch durch stellvertreter leistungen
kennzeichnenden konflikt einen prozess
zu machen in dem die menschen in libyen
endlich wieder zu ihrem recht kommen auf
ein friedliches zusammenleben
ich mache mir keine illusionen dass das
natürlich noch eine schwierige
wegstrecke sein wird und die emotionen
sind gerade glaube ich in libyen auch
sehr sehr kontrovers aber wir waren uns
alle einig dass wir angesichts des
vielen leidet das auftritt angesichts
der schrecklichen situation die wir auch
im blick auf die ausbreitung des
terrorismus in der seine zone haben es
gerechtfertigt war und ich möchte mich
bei allen teilnehmern die heute an
dieser konferenz teilgenommen haben sehr
sehr herzlich bedanken weil das eine
sehr konstruktive atmosphäre war in der
wir zusammenarbeiten können
guten abend gute nacht express
ich würde die zunächst einmal sehr
herzlich der bundeskanzlerin und der
deutschen regierung dafür danken dass
sie diese konferenz einberufen haben
frau bundeskanzlerin sie haben von
anfang an dann sozusagen enthusiastisch
aber auch konsequent eine berührung
unterstützt um libyen frieden und
stabilität zu bringen und das ist sehr
sehr bemerkenswerte und als
generalsekretär der organisation möchte
ich an dieser stelle hier meinen dank
aussprechen
die internationalen organisationen haben
ein sehr nachdrücklich signal geschickt
das bier an einer friedlichen lösung der
libyschen krise interessiert sind
zutiefst interessiert sind wird
vielleicht darf ich nur ganz kurz drei
punkte hier erwähnen
ich kann nicht nicht genug betonen dass
es keine militärische lösung für den
konflikt in libyen geben kann
darauf haben sich alle teilnehmer dieser
konferenz einigen können haben das auch
immer wieder wiederholt selbst
diejenigen bieten etwas direkter an dem
konflikt beteiligt sind
und heute haben auch alle teilnehmer
dieser konferenz sich dazu verpflichtet
in diesem bewaffneten konflikt oder die
inneren angelegenheiten libyens weiter
anzugreifen
dieses ist teil der schlussfolgerung wie
und das muss natürlich auch eingehalten
werden
ebenso wie den aufruf die waffen
schweigen zu lassen und keine weiteren
militärischen ausrüstung zur verfügung
zu stellen
wir haben außerdem auch alle akteure
dazu aufgerufen
nichts zu tun was die konflikt weiter
verschlimmern könnte und wir rufen alle
teilnehmer an diesem konflikt und auch
die internationale gemeinschaft dazu auf
das am selber das waffen- und base
entschuldigung der fermentation von
organisch zu respektieren
der politische prozess ist absolut
essentiell
und wir rufen alle parteien zu dem
konflikt dazu auf weiterhin an einem
politischen prozess unter der
schirmherrschaft der vereinten nationen
der schließlich zu einer friedlichen
lösung führen soll teilzunehmen
ich muss sagen das was diese drei
verschiedenen bereiche angeht die wir
definiert haben der wirtschaftliche
bereiche tatsächlich zu diesem
wirtschaftlichen und finanziellen fragen
die nächste wirklich stattfinden und
hier hat man sich vor allen dingen mit
den zentralen aspekten der
wirtschaftsreform die das landwirtschaft
dringend braucht konzentriert zum
beispiel die vereinheitlichung der
zentralbank die tatsache dass man die
nationale die libysche wieder in kraft
gesetzt werden muss jetzt weiter
die zweite spur sozusagen ist die
militärische fragen sind die
militärischen fragen
das war heute möglich dank der
vermittlung der bundesregierung hier auf
beiden seiten
fünf jeweils fünf personen zu ernennen
sowohl seitens der regierung des
national einvernehmens also auch seitens
general haffter es wird also nächsten
tagen in genf eintreffen dieses
medizinischen ausschusses geben und
schließlich und endlich ist es auch so
dass sowohl als repräsentant und rauch
als auch der staatsrat gesagt haben dass
sie vertreter ernennen werden
zu diesen politischen foren das wird
auch eine ganze reihe von namen
enthalten die von den vereinten nationen
vom eine sonder gesang der nation
genannt werden wir wussten dass uns das
ebenfalls ermöglicht gerade diese
politischen bereiche weiter
voranzutreiben
dazu haben sie sich zumindest heute
verpflichtet ebenfalls respektiert wird
und ich hoffe dass alle diese
verpflichtung dazu führen dass diese
ernsthafte krise für libyen beigelegt
werden kann mit politischen mitteln und
wir wollen diese gelegenheit ergreifen
und wir möchten alle dafür sorgen dass
diese verpflichtungen auch tatsächlich
eingehalten werden
ich darf der bundesregierung frau
bundeskanzlerin ihnen sehr herzlich
danken für alles was ich dafür getan
haben nachdem wir die ziele konnte die
ziele dieser konferenz die wir uns
gesteckt haben heute erreicht haben
haben wir uns sozusagen den schlüssel
besorgt mit dem wir den libyen konflikt
lösen können und jetzt geht es darum den
schlüssel ins schloss zu stecken und
auch umzudrehen
denn wir wissen dass es mit den heutigen
unterschriften alleine nicht getan ist
deshalb haben wir uns auch heute auf
einen follow up prozess verständigt wir
werden ein follow up komitee gründen
welches die umsetzung der beschlüsse von
heute sicherstellen soll die weitere
arbeit von uns mit und rest an salami
begleitet wird das heißt geleitet von
den vereinten nationen nimmt es bereits
anfang februar seine arbeit auf und auch
staaten die heute hier nicht vertreten
waren werden dazu eingeladen eingeladen
sich an diesem prozess und den vier
angedachten arbeitsgruppen sicherheits
und militärische fragen politische
fragen wirtschaftliche fragen und
humanitäre fragen zu beteiligen und für
den startschuss die konstituierung
dieses follow up komitees werden wir als
gastgeber und als co vorsitz von tieren
hier in deutschland und in der folge
sollen dann alle internationalen partner
die heute da gewesen sind und über die
noch zu entscheiden sein wird die dazu
kommen bei um die verantwortung in ihre
hände nehmen und darüber hinaus werden
wir die ergebnisse und mögliche weitere
schritte auch in den geeigneten
multilateralen formaten und sprechen
nicht nur bei den vereinten nationen
auch bereits morgen beim
der außenminister der europäischen union
wir wissen dass dass die arbeit jetzt
eigentlich erst begonnen hat und das
sicherlich ein schwieriger und
arbeitsintensiver weg noch vor uns
liegen wird aber umso wichtiger war es
heute auf dieser konferenz zu einer
einigung zu kommen und diesen geist der
zusammenarbeit den wir heute hier erlebt
haben und der deutlich über das hinaus
gehen was für bei anderen gelegenheiten
in der vergangenheit erlebt haben muss
es uns jetzt gelingen die libyschen
konfliktparteien zusammenzubringen mit
ihnen nachdem es zum waffenruhe und
waffenstillstand sicherlich zunächst
einmal gehen wird die voraussetzungen
dafür zu schaffen dass der bürgerkrieg
in libyen einer politischen lösung
zugeführt wird und wir damit in libyen
dauerhaften frieden bekommen
[Musik]
dem habe ich eigentlich nicht viel
hinzuzufügen schon gar nicht dem was der
generalsekretär gesagt
erlauben sie mir noch einmal herzlich
der bundesregierung der bundeskanzlerin
und der bundesaußenminister für die
anstrengung zu danken weil sie haben
keine mühe gespart in den vergangenen
monaten um diesen prozess voranzutreiben
es begann er begann mit einem treffen
das ich die ehre hatte mit der
bundeskanzlerin zu haben am 15 august
und dann haben wir von da an
zusammengearbeitet um dahin zu kommen wo
wir uns heute wieder finden und wie der
generalsekretär schon sagte wir sind
sehr dankbar für ihre enthusiastische
unterstützung und auch für die
unterstützung natürlich des
bundesaußenministers der generalsekretär
hat ja von den drei einsätzen den drei
spuren gesprochen innerhalb derer wir
fortschritte machen wollen
in den neun monaten der vergangenheit in
den vergangenen neun monaten hat die un
mission das land nicht verlassen die
sind in libyen geblieben und ich glaube
dass wir eine beeindruckt von der
humanitäre anstrengung unternommen haben
neben und zusätzlich zu unseren
politischen anstrengen und ich danke
allen die uns dabei geholfen haben den
menschen vor ort zu helfen es uns zu
ermöglichen auf hart zu bleiben trotz
der schwierigkeiten den wir uns
gegenüber sagt wir haben das sicherlich
auch anerkannt und ich hoffe und glaube
dass unsere anwesenheit für sie hilfe
gebracht hat und sich war ich denke
jetzt am morgen aber zunächst möchte ich
sagen dass heute ein großartiger tag
gewesen ist es gibt uns einen neuen
impuls es stärkt unseren einsatz kraft
für ein erfolg unserer bereitschaft
weiter zu machen und ich hoffe sehr dass
der sicherheitsrat der vereinten
nationen un das
der internationale ausschuss für
folgemaßnahmen in den nächsten wochen
dann das umsetzen wofür uns heute hier
in berlin geeinigt haben
ich danke herrn lang von dpa frau
bundeskanzlerin die sie haben viel von
der umsetzung gesprochen alle eigentlich
dieser vereinbarung von heute ist die
bundesregierung bereit unter umständen
auch mit der bundeswehr bei der
umsetzung und bei der implementierung
der vereinbarung dabei zu sein und das
zu unterstützen
und während sie bitte so nett könnten
sie uns schildern wie sowohl herr
sarrazin haffter in diesem prozess heute
eingebunden waren haben die zusammen mit
ihnen gesprochen waren die überhaupt bei
der konferenz dabei oder haben sie
einzeln mit den beiden gesprochen
dankeschön ja wir meinten mit den beiden
gesprochen weil die sozusagen
differenzen zwischen den beiden parteien
doch so groß sind dass sie nicht
zusammen miteinander sprechen zurzeit
sie war nicht teil der konferenz aber
sie waren dabei sozusagen räumlich
örtlich nicht im gleichen raum aber
örtlich in berlin damit wir sie auch
jeweils informieren konnten über den
stand der gespräche und ihnen auch
mitteilen konnten
es ist natürlich so dass jeder vom
anderen erstmal erwartet dass er alles
an ein held und insofern war das
eigentliche signal und das war ja auch
immer der gedanke der konferenz als sich
nicht auf 15 ob es zum ersten mal mit
salami getroffen habe hiess es wir
müssen es schaffen dass all die parteien
die in uns einer weise mit dem
libyen-konflikt verbunden sind
mit einer einzigen stimme sprechen und
das war das ziel der heutigen konferenz
denn dann werden auch die parteien
innerhalb libyens verstehen dass es nur
einen nichtmilitärischen weg zur lösung
gibt und dieses ergebnis haben wir auch
erreicht alle haben sich zu den gleichen
verpflichtungen bekannt hier und
insofern war das sehr wichtig ich finde
wir dürfen jetzt nicht den übernächsten
schritt vom ersten diskutieren und
deshalb haben heute einige teilnehmer
davon gesprochen wenn ist zu einem
dauerhaften waffenstillstand kommt und
wenn natürlich die jüdischen parteien
dazu auch bereit sind
dann könnte man auch eine überwachung
dieses waffenstillstandes müsste es ja
auch an anderen stellen haben ins auge
fassen aber darüber ist heute nicht
konkret gesprochen worden ist auch nicht
gegenstand der beschlüsse sondern jetzt
geht es erstmal darum die verschiedenen
wege zu verfolgen und der weg einen
waffenstillstand wie man ihn absichert
der spielt überhaupt erst dann eine
rolle wenn man einen dauerhaften
waffenstillstand hat uns diesen weg
haben wir heute eröffnet indem wir jetzt
erstmal diese waffenruhe haben in dem
das militär kommunität tagen wird und
der große fortschritt an dem man ihm
auch sehen konnte dass beide parteien in
gewisser weise spüren dass sie auch
konstruktiv sein muss war dass jede
partei uns fünf namen genannt hat so
dass der herr salami jetzt einladen kann
und nicht herren also nicht eine anonyme
einladung verschicken muss sondern die
teilnehmer einer solchen konferenz kennt
und das ist sozusagen der erste schritt
zur operationalisierung für die anderen
komitees sind fortschritte gemacht
worden aber das war das allerwichtigste
um jetzt überhaupt diesen stillstand
näher zu kommen und die zweite mit herrn
rinke von reuters frau bundeskanzlerin
eine frage zu der bedeutung dass der
vereinbarung über die ölvorkommen
das ist ja ein wichtiger grund gewesen
warum immer wieder geld vorhanden war um
waffen zu kaufen wie wollen sie
sicherstellen dass die milizen
tatsächlich auf die kontrolle über häfen
und öl und gasvorkommen verzichten und
herr generalsekretär eine frage an sie
wenden wo sehen sie die rolle für gerade
für die europäer bei den nächsten
schritten setzen sie darauf dass eine
mögliche überwachungs mission von den
europäern kommen wird oder denken sie da
er an die afrikanische union oder andere
partner
oder sollte europa sich zum beispiel auf
den wiederaufbau libyens oder andere
punkte konzentrieren also über die ölh
fragen müssen ja auch erst noch
gespräche geführt werden vielleicht kann
harris oder andere mieter noch mal etwas
näher dazu eigentlich oder vielleicht
auch der deutsche außenminister
natürlich ist das auch eine
voraussetzung wir haben ja im grunde
zwei dinge das eine ist die faire
aufteilung der einnahmen aus dem öl
vorkommen und das zweite ist aber jetzt
erst mal dass alle die in gewisser weise
in diesem konflikt mit involviert sind
deutlich machen es gibt keine
militärische lösung aber zu den news
spezifischer wirklich noch mal jemanden
anders bitten aber erstmal antonio
guterres
zunächst möchte ich sagen dass wir sehr
beruhigt sind angesichts der tatsache
dass einige häfen von denen aus öl
exportiert wird geschlossen und ein sehr
bedeutsames ölfeld hat die produktion
heute eingestellt
das beunruhigt uns sehr und wir sind der
auffassung dass wir teile einer viel
umfassenderen lösung sind wir brauchen
effiziente art und weise wie diese dinge
gehandhabt werden wir möchten die
normalität wiederherstellen aber dass
eine hände der erfolg bei der ein spur
hängt von den erfolgen in den
landessprachen ab aber zunächst einen
echten waffenstillstand wir können
nichts überwachen was ich noch nicht da
heißt wir haben eine waffenruhe
aber kein echter waffenstillstand eine
der zentralen fragen die wir angehen
müssen
und das ist heute so wichtig ist dass
man im betroffenen parteien die sich
irgendwie beteiligt haben sich
verpflichtet haben druck auf die
parteien die konfliktparteien ausüben
damit es einen solchen waffenstillstand
gibt wenn es ihn gibt dann müssen wir
über die überwachung nachdenken
das lässt sich auf unterschiedliche art
und weise natürlich bedeutet das dass
wir mit den konfliktparteien darüber ins
gespräch ein
treten müssen es muss auch eine lösung
sein die von beiden parteien akzeptiert
wird und er setzt auch voraus dass
seitens der sicherheitsrat dann eine
entscheidung spielen eine ganze reihe
von internationalen organisationen wird
sich dann wahrscheinlich beteiligen die
vm wird ihre aufgabe erfüllen europa
ganz zweifelsohne eine wichtige rolle zu
spielen auf der diplomatischen ebene zum
beispiel das wetter heute bei einer
konferenz deutlich und auch bei den
anstrengungen die in der vergangenheit
unternommen wurden mit dem ziel frieden
in libyen wiederherzustellen und europa
wird auch bei der vorbereitung der
verschiedenen arbeiten in den
verschiedenen spuren auf den
verschiedenen einzelnen ansätzen zu
spielen haben und wenn das dann in die
richtige richtung weitergeht wird auch
in zukunft europa eine wichtige rolle zu
spielen haben auch beim wiederaufbau
libyens
[Musik]
ich habe in den gesprächen mit
premierminister savas und fährt war
schon öfter die vor der konferenz hier
im bundeskanzleramt statt gefunden haben
auch über die frage wer blockierten
öl-häfen gesprochen
beide seiten haben sich grundsätzlich
bereit erklärt dafür eine lösung zu
finden die ist von verschiedenen
bedingungen abhängig das hat etwas damit
zu tun
die einnahmen aus dem ölverkauf verteilt
werden und über welche organisationen
und institutionen und wie diese
institution reformiert werden müssen was
das eines der themen der jetzt auf dem
tisch liegt an dem wir in den kommenden
tagen und wochen wahrscheinlich sehr
lange sitzen werden
eine frage von mph jordaans das ist er
da
ja danke eine frau bundeskanzlerin
wie sieht denn das einfrieren der
militärischen unterstützung der
kriegsparteien konkret aus also hat man
sich mit russland und der türkei
speziell jetzt auf einen zeitplan
geeinigt für die dem abzug der
unterstützung jeglicher hat sich erstmal
darauf geeinigt dass in zukunft keine
unterstützung mehr erfolgen wird und man
hat sich auch darauf geeinigt dass wir
stärker als bisher die überwachung
dieses waffenembargos auch im un
sicherheitsrat das ist ja ein un-prozess
durchsetzen wollen dazu haben sich alle
verpflichtet die frage wie jetzt schon
bestehende militärische unterstützung
sowohl was menschen als auch was
ausrüstung anbelangt abgezogen werden
die ist dann eine frage des wirklichen
waffenstillstands die ist keine frage
was man hat sie erst mal darauf geeinigt
dass man stand heute nicht weitere
waffen liefern will also das
waffenembargo einhalten das ist auch
unter das ist auch teil der erklärung ja
ja das haben sie in worms darf ich dem
noch etwas hinzufügen
seit monaten haben wir eine fortwährende
eskalation der situation erlebt in den
vergangenen letzten tagen hat das ein
dramatisches um gefährliches ausmaß
erreichen
wir erleben die situation des lümmelten
konflikt sie jetzt sehen wir das risiko
die gefahr einer echten regionalen
eskalation und dieses risiko haben wir
heute hier in berlin eingeschränkt immer
unter der maßgabe natürlich dass es uns
gelingt die feuerpause im ein
waffenstillstand zu überführen
aber das ist die gefahr die sich in den
letzten wochen und tagen deutlich
abgezeichnet hat heute haben den
ausdruck der entschlossenheit aller
betroffenen und hier anwesenden erlebt
oder zu verhindern
ein ausdruck der entschlossenheit somit
also die statements zum abschluss der
libyenkonferenz in berlin
damit willkommen zu einem heute express
spezial gleich sprechen wir mit unserer
hauptstadtkorrespondent hinzu vielleicht
noch mal eine kurze zusammenfassung
worum geht es bei der libyen-konferenz
im kern darum das land in nordafrika in
dem seit jahren ein bürgerkrieg tobte
einem frieden näher zu bringen gegenüber
stehen sich dort auf der einen seite die
von der uno anerkannten regierung in
tripolis unter premierminister als auf
der anderen seite die truppen des
abtrünnigen generals haft haben darüber
hinaus haben aber viele andere akteure
auch aus dem ausland interessen in
libyen was die situation natürlich nicht
leichter macht schauen wir vielleicht
noch mal kurz auf die wesentlichen
aussagen dieser pressekonferenz und da
muss man eben sagen das die teilnehmer
des berliner libyen-gipfel sich immerhin
zu einer einhaltung eines
un-waffenembargos verpflichtet haben und
auch ein ende der militärischen
unterstützung für die
bürgerkriegsparteien vereinbart haben
dass also die zentrale botschaft
bundeskanzlerin merkel lobte noch einmal
den geist der zwölf teilnehmer starten
die sich insgesamt dort beteiligt haben
und hat auch noch einmal unterstrichen
wie wichtig eben auch die engmaschigen
kontrollen jetzt sei dieser waffenruhe
und in ähnlicher weise hat sich geäußert
auch der un-generalsekretär gut er ist
sagte auch es gibt eben keine
militärische lösung für diesen konflikt
der muss politisch gelöst werden und
darüber wollen wir sprechen mit unserer
hauptstadt korrespondentin mit nicole
diekmann die uns zugeschaltet ist in
berlin schönen guten abend frau
dieckmann also ziel der konferenz war ja
die jüngst vereinbarte feuerpause zu
festigen und auch eben ein dauerhaftes
waffenembargo zu vereinbaren und nach
dem was man also bislang hören konnte
ist man diesem ziel ja ganz
offensichtlich näher gekommen
dem ist man näher gekommen wir haben das
ja gerade in der pressekonferenz gehört
man hat sich darauf geeinigt das
waffenembargo das ja schon seit 2011
seit dem sturz des ehemaligen
machthabers gaddafi besteht einzuhalten
man hat sich darauf geeinigt dass die es
ist ein stellvertreterkrieg da in libyen
dass die beteiligten staaten ausserhalb
libyens aufhören waffen zu liefern und
man hat sich darauf geeinigt dass
schärfer zu überwachen das ist das was
im moment auf dem tisch liegt ja kann
man denn da jetzt schon von einem großen
wurf sprechen oder wie ist das ihrer
einschätzung nach jetzt
von einem großen wurf kann man nicht
sprechen aber den hatte man hier auch in
berlin in dieser sehr hektischen woche
nach diesem sehr kurzfristig anberaumten
gipfel gar nicht mehr in aussicht
gestellt da waren die erwartungen schon
sehr gedämpft worden man weiß hier wie
schwierig die lage ist angela merkel hat
ja auch gerade in der pressekonferenz
gesagt sie machen sich keine illusionen
es sei eine schwierige wegstrecke
es sind viele fragen offen geblieben zum
beispiel wie will man sicherstellen dass
das waffenembargo tatsächlich auch
eingehalten wird von staaten wie den
vereinigten arabischen emiraten der
türkei und den russen was passiert wenn
diese sich nicht an das embargo halten
werden sie sanktioniert darauf gab es
eben keine antwort was will man dafür
tun dass jetzt lediglich diese
waffenpause eingehalten wird und soll es
eine schutztruppe geben um diese waffen
oder diese feuerpause sagen was man so
man will wir reden ja von sehr sehr
kleinen schritten sicherzustellen angela
merkel wurde eben gefragt von einem
journalisten ob deutschland sich
beteiligen wolle mit soldaten um eben
sicherzustellen dass die waffen jetzt
schweigen
darauf sagt sie das sei der erste
schritt vor der zweite schritt vor dem
ersten
nun müsse man erst mal sehen ob diese
waffenruhe auch halte also da beißt sich
die katze ein bisschen in den schwanz es
sind wie gesagt viele viele fragen offen
reden wir über das was eben jetzt schon
bekannt ist unter anderem ja auch die
tatsache zumindest war es so zu hören
dass die beiden libyschen gegenspieler
sich jetzt direkt gar nicht begegnet
sind auf dieser presse beziehungsweise
auf dieser konferenz
inwieweit beeinträchtigt oder schwächt
dass das verhandlungsergebnis
ich würde das anders formulieren das
zeigt wie diffizil wie verfahren wie
schwierig und hoch explosiv die lage in
diesem land ist man ist nicht nur hier
schon erleichtert darüber und geradezu
euphorisch dass man es geschafft hat
starten die direkt oder indirekt an
diesem bürgerkrieg beteiligt sind an
einen tisch bekommen zu haben und unter
einer erklärung nein es ist auch ein
erfolg dass sowohl haffter der
selbsternannte feldmarschall als auch
der international anerkannte präsident
faraj in berlin waren gleichzeitig und
zumindest getrennt voneinander
aber wenigstens gesprochen haben sowohl
mit der kanzlerin als auch mit dem
außenminister heiko maas das heißt der
graben ist so tief der riss ist so tief
da steht noch eine menge arbeit an was
auf jeden fall auch clever war der
enorme aufwand betrieben worden ist um
diese konferenz überhaupt stattfinden zu
lassen und natürlich auch um sie zu
einem erfolg zu führen warum ist
eigentlich für deutschland für europa
dieser konflikt in libyen so wichtig ja
das ist ein krieg der tipp vor der
haustür und was ein ganz herausragender
punkt ist auch für angela merkel dass
hier heute war zwar eine außenpolitische
veranstaltung das ist aber auch
knallharte innenpolitik den libyen hat
sich entwickelt zum wichtigsten land auf
dem weg nach europa für flüchtlinge das
war hier heute immer wieder zu hören
auch in den letzten tagen eben als diese
konferenz vorbereitet wurde
man will kein zweites syrien das heißt
übersetzte in politik man will dass die
flüchtlingsfrage hier nicht wieder
aufkommt wir erinnern und 2015 2016 die
bundesregierung stand vor der
zerreißprobe
die union stand kurz vor der
zerreißprobe und ein zweites mal möchte
man durch so eine krise hier sicherlich
nicht gehen also die libyen konferenz in
berlin war ein anfang wie könnte der weg
zu einem dauerhaften frieden jetzt
konkret weitergehen was haben sie da der
konferenz der pressekonferenz entnehmen
können erstmal berät morgen um halb zehn
in brüssel beraten die eu-staaten über
das was wir heute erzielt worden ist und
dann gibt es ein sogenanntes 55 militär
komitee dass in den kommenden tagen
konkreter wurde das jetzt eben auch
nicht benannt in genf tagen soll das
bedeutet beide bürgerkriegsparteien
schicken je fünf leute in dieses komitee
die dann weiter beraten sollen und auch
das zeigt nochmal die fallhöhe dieser
veranstaltung man ist schon sehr
erleichtert und hat es eben als erfolg
erklärt zum erfolg erklärt dass je eine
kriegspartei je fünf leute genannt hat
das ist jetzt erst mal der nächste
schritt und dann soll bereits anfang
februar unter schirmherrschaft der
vereinten nationen
das hat
der aussenminister maß eben noch mal
skizziert ein sogenanntes follow up
komitee ins leben gerufen werden dass
auch hier in berlin dann sich treffen
soll und engmaschig wie er sagt die
beschlüsse sicherstellen also es
passiert jetzt im moment viel auf der
diskursiven ebene was embargos angeht
was zum beispiel eine blauhelmtruppe
angeht und so das ist noch in weiter
ferne
vielen dank nicole diekmann für diese
einschätzung zur libyen konferenz in
berlin waren eine menge stoff vielen
dank dass sie uns das alles ein bisschen
näher gebracht und eingeordnet haben
dankeschön soweit unser heute express
spezial zur konferenz in berlin vielen
dank für ihr interesse alle reaktionen
und ergebnisse können sie sich auch auf
heute.de nochmal genauer nachlesen ihnen
noch einen schönen sonntagabend